OB
Mobius!
We have a little bit of a situation.
We wanted to run by you, Mobius. Wow.
Great to see you again.
That.
That's what's been happening.
Wow. Time slipping where you times.
You know that? Yeah.
You've seen that?
Yeah. Can you fix that? No.
It's impossible to be in the TVA.
I know, but we just saw it happen.
Yeah,
I've been pulled through time
between the past and the present.
Hello?
If what I saw was true,
there's nothing to stand
between this world and utter destruction.
Only one way to find out.
A little good old fashioned legwork.
Listen, we have different styles.
You're a man of action, which is fine.
I take a more slow, deliberate,
cerebral approach.
It's really good. By.
It's up to us
to save this place.
Is this crack?
Is it?
Whatever we do,
we're playing God
be our gods.
But how do you choose
who lives
and who dies?
Think the hard choice.
You better
walk away.
Come on.
You're the God of mischief.
Always have been and always will be.
Over the top, don't you think?
I thought it was spot on.
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
There's a brand new Loki season
two trailer, so we'll break it all down.
There's a whole bunch Easter eggs here.
I know there are a lot of questions
about how this crosses over
with the events of Deadpool 3
because the TVA is a big part of that too.
So if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes
This will be coming after the Asoka
episodes are done.
I'll be doing videos for that
starting in a couple of weeks.
When that releases,
they'll be eight episodes of that six
episodes of Loki Season two,
just like season one, though,
just starting at the beginning
of the trailer footage
and working our way through, shot by shot,
talking about Easter eggs,
wtf moments in the Deadpool of it all.
They start with Loki and Mobius
going to the TVA's Tech support room
to get some help from Kahui
Cuan, who's playing Aura Barrows,
who's basically like the tech support guy
for the entire TVA.
most of you have probably just seen him
in everything everywhere all at once,
which is another great multiverse movie,
probably one of the best multiverse movies
ever.
It's kind of
what Doctor Strange should have been.
he says Loki is time slipping
and he's basically uncontrollably
jumping around in his own timeline
within the TVA.
And that shouldn't happen because of the
way the King set the TVA up.
There's a new version of the Loki
Marvel Studios intro that shifts
the red throughout the trailer.
We see him time
slipping in a couple different places.
This is just
one of the interrogation rooms
he slips to a jet ski dealership,
which is a reference to all of mobius
jet skis in the nineties
that he's obsessed with
because that's
where he originally came from.
Probably really hoping he gets that jet
ski at some point, maybe during Deadpool
that feels appropriate.
part of the joke here, too,
is that he's just flailing his arms around
like the advertising blowup doll
Piranha is a brand of jet ski,
but you could also call that a reference
to Kang the Conqueror
or the Kang Multiverse
War, the Council of Kings being sort of
like piranhas in the water of time
you don't see time
slips and sees himself in the tbey
like he crosses over with his own
personal timeline within the TBA.
zoom in. Enhance.
You also see what looks like this crazy
readout on the screen of what's happening
with the timeline.
it also looks like
there's an error message up on the board
and he's trying to read in this manual
to find more information about this
error message.
this is Sylvie back in what looks like
the 1970s where she's working at
that McDonald's at a record store
with what looks like a record.
Traveling together through time.
But just the record itself.
this is a scene of Loki
trying to reveal to Mobius
and all the other people that are part
of this new timeline of the TVA.
What's really going on with Kang
the Conqueror?
Like he tries to open up this wall here
to show them the truth of Kang behind it.
I think what happens
at the very beginning of the season is
he has to do a speed run explainer
for everything that happened during season
one to all these different characters,
including Mobius, who's offscreen right
here, just to tell them the truth of Kang
the Conqueror unveiling that behind this
wall here, behind the fake timekeepers.
You also notice
he's already chopped the head
off of one of the timekeeper robots.
part of the idea is that he's Sylvie.
In any one from the Council of Kang's
like the victor Timely Kang
are the only people who actually remember
what happened in the previous timeline.
them in the elevator here
seems that they're going to the basement
to visit Aura Burrows.
And that's where his lab is.
Or where his workshop is.
The very basement of the TVA.
They go back to the 1800s.
And this is meant to be where that victor
timely Kang is.
That's why the fair looks like
it's an 1800s looking bear
this person
isn't like another version of carnage,
just like a random person
who works here during this time period.
you notice,
they have all these different banners
from all the different
nations of the world made
to look kind of medieval with shields.
Then they combine
a couple of different episodes together.
So it's him talking to Loki in the 1800s,
but they use footage from them
in the 1970s.
Completely different episode
going after Raphael Casal,
who's playing the Zenia character.
So part of the idea
is that even though they're trying
to unravel the mystery of Kang
the Conqueror
and what's happening with the time
slipping the K Multiverse war.
Victor Timely.
Kang There's a bunch of different Kang's
that are going after.
But also they're still going
after regular variants that are causing
Nexus events like the Zodiac person,
we see Loki using his magic
during a couple of different scenes
back in the 1800s,
but also during that 1970s ENIAC episode.
Mobius continues talking to Loki
the same conversation, but they crossover
footage of them
in an automat inside the TVA
This is them arriving at that 1970s
ENIAC premiere.
There are a whole bunch of Easter eggs
during this.
movie, Zany Act is a huge Easter egg
because Zany Act is an actual
Marvel character from the comics.
But in the Marvel Universe, Zany Act
was kind of like the essence or the spirit
of a serial killer who would possess
different people's bodies across time.
Using supernatural means.
the reason why they're using him on
the Loki series
is because he appeared for the first time
in the Thor comics, and this is Loki.
So obviously Thor connection. You get it.
but the star of the movie, Brad
Wolf, is another Easter egg,
because in the Marvel Universe,
in the comics,
he was just a regular actor
who signed on to play a fictional version
of the zany character
in a movie inside the Marvel Comics.
but then when he was dressed
like the zany character,
they started
filming the movie, doing his scenes.
He had an accident
and was mutated into the actual zany
character possessed by his spirit,
turned into a killer,
try to kill a bunch of the crew members
until Thor stopped him
and they threw him in an insane asylum.
So if you remember
the Guardians of the Galaxy
two deleted scenes with the Wonder
Man character played by Nathan Fillion,
like he played a version of that character
in the universe,
but he was an actor pretending
to be these different characters,
so the kind of doing the same thing, it's
the same energy with this zany act movie,
But basically during Loki season two,
it seems like they're doing a version
of that zany Zach
origin story, except when the actor gets
turned into the real zany
going crazy
trying to kill a bunch of people.
It's Loki who stops them
from killing everyone instead of Thor.
in if you zoom in, enhanced on the movie
poster
credits here for all the other actors
names, the production crew members names.
The production company is listed
as a Goodman production.
That's a huge Easter egg for the origin
of the Marvel comic book company itself.
Originally,
the company was owned by Martin Goodman.
who owned Timely Comics.
That was the original name of Marvel
Comics.
He's the one who hired a young
Stan Lee, Jack Kirby, all those classic
era Marvel creators that, you know.
then later, the company changed
its name a couple of times,
eventually changing it to Marvel Comics.
They've used the Martin
Goodman Productions, Easter Egg
a couple of times in the Marvel Universe.
They used it during Moon Knight, too,
when they're revealing the true
origin of the Stephen
Grant persona that he was a character
in a fictional movie called Tomb Busters.
The production
company of that movie on the poster
was listed as Timely Atlas Productions.
that was another Easter egg
for Timely Comics.
But what happened is,
is it started out as timely comics.
Then in the 1950s,
they changed their name to Atlas Comics.
Then after that,
they changed their name to Marvel Comics.
the next Easter Egg is that movie
that Kingo made in the 1970s and a lot of
you will probably remember this movie
from the Eternals movie.
like they reference it
in a couple of different Marvel movies.
you remember King goes back story
he was with Sprite until he left her
in Macedonia and went to India
to become a Bollywood movie star.
the first real big movie
that he starred in.
Later in the timeline was Son of Soroush.
And that is the poster that you're seeing
on this wall here.
end, at the time, he was pretending
to be his great great grandfather.
in what would happen
is that he would just disappear
after a little while and resurface
as that person son,
and then after a certain amount of time
had passed
by, he'd do the same thing again and again
until eventually you get the Kingo
that you see today
He joked that
his assistant Karun, came along
and thought that he was a vampire when he
started to notice that he would not age.
was the
actual vampires in the MCU
during the Blade movie
there are a couple other Easter eggs
with these other movie posters, too.
But some of these are posters for movies
that were released in real life.
So I think the events of this episode,
this movie release that they're going to
this theater is taking place
during the year 1974 in the MCU
because all these movies are from posters
for movies that were released in 1974.
like this is the real poster
for a movie called Airport 1975.
This is a poster for a movie
called Earthquake.
this is a poster for the real life
lovebug sequel
called Herbie Rides Again,
which was released by Disney in 1974.
so I think that confirms that Kingo
son of Suresh movie
that his great great grandfather
supposedly made, even though it was real.
Kingo was also released in 1974.
the next big Easter Egg
is on another poster for a movie
called Lone Ranger
who yes, as ridiculous as that sounds,
is another actual Marvel character
from the comics in the comics.
Phone Ranger was a character named A.G.
Bell like Bell Phone Systems.
That was an actual phone company.
he started out as a telephone
repairman who was sent to fix a phone
that a known to anyone was actually acting
as a prison for a small race of aliens
known as the Salters.
AG Bell wound up using the technology
that the alien race left in the phone,
replicating it
and use it to give himself the power
to tap into any communications technology.
using that power to become a superhero
fighting crime.
the like his actual costume
kind of looks like a phone person.
the star of that movie,
though, is Charles Theobald.
The only reference in connection
I could think to
Marvel Comics is a Brigadier
Theobald Inkblot in the comics,
who was a supporting character
from Excalibur, who has ties to physics,
but if you look here
the production company for this phone
Ranger movie is also Goodman Productions.
we see a version of Hunter B-15 come back.
I'm not sure which time period this is.
And it might also be in the 1970s.
we see Sylvie working at that McDonald's.
It was a bunch of footage
that that came out last year
when they were still filming it.
it also seems like they wind up
chasing the zodiac person to this place.
So it might be happening
in the exact same episode.
zoom in and hands on her
a little name badge.
She's got all those gold stars on it
mean that she is a model employee,
which seems very weird for Sylvie.
Like she's really trying to hide out.
But if you remember, she usually tries
to hide out in apocalypse events,
meaning that something terrible
might wind up happening to this McDonald's
and This is part of a much bigger fight
Loki has with a bunch of TVA agents
inside the TVA,
with all of them coming out for him
with a whole bunch of different portals.
it looks like Sylvie is a big part of this
fight to We see some of the remnants
of the end of Loki season one with he
who remains Citadel at the end of time.
this is probably just to address
what happens right
at the beginning of the season
then there's the scene of K
who expands or borrows
putting Mobius in a special TBAs suit
and it looks like what
he is sending him to inspect is basically
like the unfettered time stream
that's gone all chaotic.
love the way he patches together
the suit with duct tape.
I'll be fine.
You be fine. Just get out there.
Buddy they had a bunch of these suits
on display at Comic-Con.
you notice, the time stream is unraveling
like the past is unraveling
as they go forward in time.
this was what was on that air
message board earlier in the trailer.
it's like time itself is coming apart
completely at the seams
this is them actually arresting zany.
I and bringing him back
to be processed at the TVA.
Then everything's going crazy at the TVA
in a completely different scene.
this is a scene of Loki and Mobius
actually walking into the automat to talk
and have some food.
Sylvie comes back to the TVA
in that same automat to talk with them.
Not sure who Sylvie is going
after with her knife in this scene
that looks a little bit like Loki,
but I think it's actually meant to be
somebody else Loki makes the joke
that they are actual gods.
Like literally in mythologically
they are gods,
Remember,
they're meant to be the gods of mischief
this is them still back in the 1970s
going after Zodiac
but Loki pulls the same trick
that he pulled
during the first Avengers movie
where he duplicates himself.
You see the horns start growing
out of his head as he makes the allusions.
then we finally see the version of Ravana
Ren Slayer, who escaped
at the end of season one that was worn by
he who remains king based on the way
she's dressed.
It looks like she's back in the 1800s
to the same place where the victor
timely Kang is.
the meter Loki is reading here
probably is a tie back to the actual logo
turning to red in the red line,
pi just means time is unraveling
and probably something to do with time
completely coming apart at the seams.
this scene of Loki talking about
how do you choose?
Looks like
it's at the beginning of the season
when they arrest him
because they don't know who he is
and he has to explain everything
from season one.
this is the version of Hunter B-15
in another timeline who was a doctor
there's a portal that opens
right behind her
looking like somebody coming to either
prune her or do something with her
not sure which version of Cassie
this is walking through an alleyway.
It might be the same Cassie
from the very end of the season,
when he came back to the TVA
like the new version of Cassie
in the new timeline was way more badass
than the previous version.
then they basically replay the Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantumania Post-Credits
scene with them, finding the Victor time.
Looking at that 1800s, they're like,
That's why they've come to the fair
in the first place.
in. He's basically
explaining the concept of controlling time
in a very Nikola Tesla
kind of way back during the 1800s.
supposedly there's
going to be a bunch of different king
variants that they're going
after during this season,
and this is just one of them
Miss Minutes comes back,
but it's sort of like an old timey
looking version of Miss Minutes.
This created by the victor Timely.
KANG Like this
Kang is the one who created her.
So that's why
the color is all desaturated.
Because we're back.
During the 1800s,
this is another scene of Loki trying to
explain the Kang Multiverse War,
which is depicted on the walls of the TVA.
notice that all these different
things are dressed like classic
comic book Kang the Conqueror.
this looks like the scene before they
put Mobius in that special space suit.
Look, they're inspecting the timeline,
completely unraveling.
this is the control room of the TVA.
Completely unraveling the same way we see
the timeline unraveling like the mist.
This message is basically saying
you're completely screwed.
Thank you for your service.
Time is over now. Completely done.
This looks like Ravana
ren slayer in the 1800s clothing.
But on the void planet
at the end of time, Loki
looking around the wider TBA and
everything is just going completely crazy.
and they end the trailer
with Loki talking to Mobius, confirming
that he is, in fact, the God of mischief.
Always have been, always will be.
you notice when the Loki logo
is cycling to the letters
are broken like time itself is broken So.
It seems like the beginning of the season
is him just explaining to Mobius
and everyone else what actually happened.
The truth of Kang
then then finding Sylvie
back in the 1970s, hiding it a McDonald's.
then then going after a bunch of different
Kang's like Victor timely Kang
in trying to fix the whole mystery
of what's happening with the timeline,
completely unraveling at the seams
that's meant to get in the whole concept
of the Kang Multiverse War
and the incursions with universes
collapsing or colliding with each other
all over the place,
which is a slightly separate thing,
but kind of related The whole idea
is that all of these different universes
are either colliding or being destroyed
in some way until you get down
to the remnants of one single universe
for all of reality, with one single world,
which is Battle world.
And that's the Avengers secret war,
basically
this is meant to directly lead up
to Avengers five, Qing Dynasty, though,
which is the dynasty of kings coming
after all the heroes
like not just the Avengers,
but a bunch of different characters
from different universes.
in they're kind of doing a new version of
the Kang Multiverse War, but showing you
the actual Kang Multiverse war
with like crazy special effects
like the Throne million dollar
version of the Kang Multiverse War.
some of the upcoming Marvel Phase
five movies will set that up
and some of the more connected to
what's happening in Captain America
for a New World Order
in the more Earth based plot
like the Marvel Dark reign of it all.
there've been a lot of conflicting reports
about when Deadpool three
takes place in the timeline.
Like does it take place before
or after Loki season two.
but the whole idea is that
Deadpool is jumping around in the timeline
with cable's time travel device in.
Mobius sets the TVA after him
to prune him as a variant.
while he's jumping around, he winds up
going back to the 838 universe.
And the rumor is that they're going
to turn that into a house of M reality
where Magneto takes over the planet
and mutants reign supreme.
And that's where he finds this
comic book accurate.
Looking version of Wolverine.
we'll start getting a bunch more trailers
for this during the Asoka episodes.
Of course, they'll do more videos,
but if you spotted any other Easter
eggs or references during this
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
I've already done a much longer Deadpool
three video.
They've already been filming.
There's a whole bunch of footage.
So click here to watch that and click here
for all my other Comic-Con
trailer videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!